de quel genre de ligne droite on parle
peu importe ce cas sur notre chemin et
falling parfaitement droites et mental
on creuse des rivières on creuse des
marécages on creuse on creuse on creuse
ce que je veux savoir pourquoi vous
faites cette ligne notre but est
d'obtenir les cotations boursières en
seize mille secondes ce qui est une
milice seconde plus rapide que n'importe
qui d'autre
ok mais après qu'est ce qui se passe
c'est 500 millions de dollars par an
pourquoi te demande tu pas eva torres
eva torres se sert des gens comme des
actifs à liquider je peux faire de ta
vie un enfant on fera l'aller-retour en
15000 secondes vous ai déjà dit qu'on ne
pouvait plus moi je te dis que ça se
peut tu crois qu'elle construit sa
propre ligne
[Musique]
faire des militants de la lutte contre
la crise à tous que ça ici au quelqu'un
infiltrés notre des champions
le basque et les allées ce qui arrivait
et pourquoi est ce qui est petit détour
cellule a maintenant qui est appliquée
il essaie simplement de le baiser
slovaque écroulé je dois rentrer à mon
métier gimme that main mais je vous
rappelle dans deux ou trois heures
pourriez vous envoyer la soumission mon
bureau que j'aimerais que ce soit réglé
d'ici la fin de journée
faut voir ça comme david des marchands
sur le parquet de la bourse avec le plus
gros slingshot qui existe
terrasson cognac qui s'écroule hd et on
est david ouais ouais on est david